foreign
[Music]
people are entering AI from all walks of
life and sometimes people still wonder
is AI a right path for me the truth is
if I could enter AI back then more than
20 years ago today anybody can enter AI
because AI has become such a prevalent
and
globally impactful technology you
actually started out not studying
computer science or AI but you start out
studying physics and so how did you make
that switch from physics to AI physics
was my passion all the way through you
know middle school high school college
and one thing physics has taught me till
today is really the passion for asking
big questions the the passion for
seeking North Stars and one thing I did
was reading up
stories and just writings of great
physicists of the 20th century it was
really interesting to notice that many
of the writings towards the later half
of the career of these great physicists
were not about just the physical world
but ponderings about equally audacious
questions like life like intelligence
like human conditions that really got me
very curious about the topic of
intelligence one thing led to another
during college time I did intern at a
couple of labs especially Vision related
and I was like wow this is just as
audacious a question to ask as the
beginning of the universe or what is
matter made of and that got me to switch
from undergraduate degree in physics to
graduate degree in AI so I think it is
very exciting to be entering the signs
of intelligence and and studying AI
today
[Music]